l'ho vinto vinto ho vinto bella tutti
ragazzi benvenuto questo video sono fa
vj set oggi siamo su una roba [ __ ] ma
veramente [ __ ] allora ragazzi avete
presente tutti credo geometri dash che
un gioco bello perché praticamente
ragazzi esiste un gioco chiamato dub
smash dub def che sarebbe tipo geometri
da sci in 3d iniziamo con uno molto
semplice tipo questa data gli altri sono
tutti bloccati
quindi per forza lo sapevi scegli il
bottone che cazzo vuoi che sappia appena
cominciato ad un secondo
non so come si gioca ragazzi premi a
sinistra bene
partenza da dio premi a sinistra per
schivare gli ostacoli ok anche quindi io
devo solo premere a destra a sinistra
quanto al film è quasi uguale a geometri
lascio solo che è in 3d
credo che premia destra per scrivere io
stia bene
tanti ragazzi va più a ritmo questo che
geometri nasce una figata pazzesca tipo
che cazzo serve una nota vabbè ma è
semplice per adesso come faccio a
sbagliare la voglio che canzone è questo
allenamento come suoneria
no no no no no no ha chiamato ci ho
fatto che culo sono anch'io come va bene
e non lo fare chi cazzo parlo a fare
ma porca [ __ ] eva incastrata nelle
panchine del duomo veramente volete di
me io non ci sto riuscendo
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah e metti su ste mani
cazzo ma [ __ ] sto zitto anche se
mi viene da ballarla canticchiare con un
deficiente sul sito perfetto tieni
premuto a sinistra per saltare che
vorrebbe piazzare skrillex c'è una nota
lusso che cazzo servano ma va bene cioè
spiegatemi il senso di studi dal nostro
caffè dice io salto se tengo premuto
salto va bene potresti non morire per
favore che siamo alla fine che potrei
incazzarmi grazie ok ho vinto vinto
vittorito ti muore la madre nora gamma
non c'è proprio umano ma che cazzo vuol
dire 99,30 che sei scemo c'era una nota
l'ho presa perché ci stava lì ma che
cazzo vuol dire 99,39 devo rifarmi no
tutto c'è per una cazzo di nota che non
servono manco ad per pulirsi il culo
allora allargano piano piano porca eva
piano in culi
che cosa serviva a quella roba
spiegatemelo perchè non ha senso massive
dei massive massimi un'altra cosa è
ma andiamo avanti che quanti ce ne sanno
pratica i ragazzi by jil the g
degeneration bello il nome c'era più
facile il nome del livello che il nome
tuo zio però fatti due domande sì però è
un po un bordello mi dicono anche
all'inizio però se non solo morto e non
so come sia possibile fini premuto per
volare per volare cosa ma va che questo
questo è una figata rea è questa una
figata
tieni premuto per volare ma cosa avremmo
c'è ditelo almeno che non schiaccio
tasti a caso cioè se prima sono morto
qua devo praticamente farci la tomba ok
perfetto prova 50 per cento la primo
tentativo non è ma pensavo peggio
sesto cuore tra l'altro mi fa ripartire
da lì ma dai che figo o 5 cuori
ragazzino già usato uno ea non vorrei
dire che figata sa cosa dei cuori non
c'era in geometri è mica stanno andando
storto di mio suocero ho già capito
questi conigli uso tutti posto livello
ormai è così son convinto no non mi
squilla telefono sfilate porta aramis
qui la terra in questo momento mi devi
squillare il telefono no frate dai
vaffan cuore ma perché mi chiamano
adesso ma che cazzo volete la mia cosa
vuoi chi è chi è chi cazzo è ma vai via
vai di ragazzi non ho più cuori e ve lo
dico sono solo ciao solo quelli o lo
sfrutto bene ho perso non è servita bene
che culo spiegami quale problema al
cervello c'hai spi mag in melo proprio
esplicava esplicamene esaurito le vite
dice vine altre superando la sfida va
bene la sorella putrefatta in forse
ancora in putrefazione devo decidere
viene pronto per volare ok tieni premuto
comunque amici miei poteva veramente
essere qualsiasi ruffato anche premere
col pene non me lo scrive se lo scrive
ragazzino tener premuto se non tengo
premuto muoio l'hotel è premuto
ok ok ti ringrazio dio che mi ha
ricordato vabbè che bordello piano che
se sbatto contro la cosa non si tornò
mai più questo punto lo dico per l'amor
di dio non ci sono mai più qua non ci
arriverò mai più ragazzo pronto 20 mila
volte
[Applauso]
c'era ancora un pezzo [ __ ] cazzo
ne so se il livello è finito ma che
cazzo ne so ma ditemelo 98 almeno fallo
a 95 non lo so non ho proprio deve
essere paura percentuale alla fine
perché io devo farmi incazzare ma per
l'amor di dio non morire ti supplico
cosa devo fare poi che non mi dico come
sono morto prima non lo so perché tanto
marino di nuovo già usati o pensate che
14 tentativi sono durati un'ora e mezza
cioè perché per un lusso livello dura
un'eternità e mezzo cioè il 20 volte
quello di geometri la tortura cinese
maori e il bello è che siamo sulla
targhetta facile questa è la mela verde
un osso pensare che quella gialla come
cazzo sta messa secondo guarda ragazzi
fanno il terzo che già che ci siamo
anche questo scegli il bottone con la
bandiera zio guarda sono in un momento
in cui da capire e decidere qualcuno
meno tentativo 1 aspetta aspetta che
dopo capi delle cose qua non ci stanno
manga i cuori perfetto ha forse deve
oltrepassare almeno un portale sono ma
li mette ok ok allora facciamo così non
li usiamo i cuori che usiamo solo quando
so più o meno come fatto a livello
ho deciso la gara un tentativo solo
deciso ho deciso adesso
donna che bordello ciò il mal di mare
ragazzi che non c'è il mare questo è un
problema cioè il mal di geometri tocca
quante cose devo leggere sto giocando a
un gioco leggermente difficile fratello
se vuoi scrivermi la divina commedia
magari non la leggo non so se è presente
comunque ho capito quello che ha detto
devo premere c'è va bene che dio santo
benedetto gesù e ce la sto facendo e
devo stare anche il sito devo stare lo
stare zitto perchè so già che mi porto
sfiga però sto facendo attenzione
attenzione
cos'è sta roba poche calmi ora gara un
tentativo è uno solo impossibile non ci
credo mai ed è 20 volte più difficili
volo di prima e quello che è strano ma
che cazzo è una canzone de martin garris
[Musica]
dai frate l'ex alla madonna che succede
al cielo figlia che giornata del merda
ragazzi un tentativo solo uno stop non
ci posso credere
madonna cosa salvato cosa salvato questo
salvato
[Musica]
capuana e vabbè vabbè al contrario gesù
santo c'è già è tanto che vado dritto
non è vero non è possibile non è
possibile ma ce l'ho fatta in un
tentativo non è possibile ma quando mai
cazzo mi ricapita st cose lo ha fatto in
un [ __ ] tentativo lo so come va bene
non fate domande non le voglio sentire
quasi inizia col giallo ci sono un po di
livelli mi dicono mi sa che non ce la
faccio in un episodio hanno facebook che
bello so con chi sfogarvi ragazzi
mandiamo un bel messaggino ma li
mortacci lost cosa cazzo gli ho scritto
voglio vedere se mi rispondono quindi
ragazzi spero che vide vi sia piaciuto
concludo che l'episodio perché gesù
buono magari anche no per adesso no
spero che video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
e cosa se tu sei video piaciuto al suo
commento mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook e credito attraverso schizzi
avessero se questi si scateni ci
vendiamo non fossimo vito è da ragazzi